la primera mujer de una comunidad étnica
marginalizada en llegar a la presidencia
de la india este jueves grupa de murmur
fue elegida presidenta con más de la
mitad de los votos del parlamento es
default pro france works secure baiseri
matic drop de murmur ya que los votos de
primera preferencia obtenidos por tour
para dibujo fueron superior a la cuota
requerida declaró en mi condición de
escrutador que grupa de murga ha sido
debidamente elegida como presidenta de
la india y la cta
of thee presidenta ofendió con 64 años y
proveniente de la tribu santa del este
del país murmu se convierte en la
segunda mujer presidenta de la india
para un período de 5 años empezó su
carrera como instructora antes de entrar
en política y ocupar cargos
ministeriales
había sido propuesta como candidata por
el primer ministro muy y una victoria
casi asegurada por adelantado ya que el
primer ministro tiene la mayoría en el
parlamento
me alegro del apoyo de todos mis colegas
políticos de todos los ministros
diputados y legisladores al elegirme
como decimoquinta presidenta del mayor
país democrático del mundo su elección
tiene una gran importancia simbólica
pero ya que el cargo es principalmente
ceremonial no tendría que producir
mayores cambios para las comunidades
tribales que son relegadas a los
márgenes de la sociedad murmu sucede a
rne that cooling el presidente
procedente de la comunidad dálits
conocida como los intocables